darius how are you
i'm great man how you doing today i am
doing fantastic there's a lot of people
who are not doing so fantastic prices of
all assets continue to sell off
aggressively
what is your read in terms of uh kind of
where we are in markets i think we spoke
last week
you made a couple of calls that seem to
be playing out pretty well here so what
what's your general read on on asset
prices across the board
yeah so we can i will speak to bitcoin
specifically later but let's just take
the kind of 30 000 view of where we are
in the broader liquidity cycle so
obviously we continue to see a lot of
pain on the screen when you look at
stock markets credit markets etc one
thing that was really interesting this
week is you finally started to see
bond prices go up as stock prices go
down that is very new as it relates to
this particular cycle and it's an
indication that the bond market at least
you know the investors on the several
hundred trillion dollar bond market
globally are starting to get concerned
about the growth outlook obviously
inflation continues to be very uh
unhinged and but clearly the growth the
shift to focusing on growth is now
something the bond market's concerned
about that's obviously got uh the
digital asset space uh concerned as well
so when you start to look at um kind of
bond market uh it seems like many people
are maybe confused or surprised in terms
of equity prices coming down yields a
little bit higher you've got the pricing
of interest rates like when you look at
that is this how you would have expected
it to play out or has there been some
surprises there uh in terms of the
relationship between equities and bonds
uh risk assets and you know maybe more
value type assets
yeah so this year has been uh
particularly uh interesting you know
we've all been sort of operating in this
post-gfc global financial crisis era and
particularly a post-gfc sort of kind of
configuration of monetary policy and as
a result of that we've all been
conditioned to expect
bonds to rally as stocks and risk assets
like bitcoin et cetera go down in price
that has not been the case this year and
part of the reason that has not been the
case then the predominant reason has not
been the case is because inflation has
been significantly above target above
trend uh and significantly above levels
that it historically uh sort of
catalyzed and perpetuated the inverse
covariance between those two asset
classes now that is starting to come
back uh to what we've considered to be
normal uh in the last kind of 12 years
or so but there's no guarantee that we
we have crossed that bridge fully um i
think from the perspective of where we
are in the broader liquidity cycle it is
clear to me that um just from another
surprise
this is happening much faster than we've
seen uh the kind of degradation in
previous kind of uh crashes uh if you
will uh in the post-crisis era um part
of the reason that we're seeing so much
the speed of the declines um and really
the timing with which the declines are
occurring vis-a-vis the growth and
liquidity cycles is partially because of
this new feature we have in financial
markets which is called forward guidance
core guidance isn't particularly new
but what is new in this in this uh
slowdown
is that the fed is using forward
guidance as a tool to tighten monetary
policy historically forward guidance has
predominantly been used by policymakers
to give
confidence to investors to go take risk
we got your back things are going to be
better uh big daddy's here to save the
day uh now they're using their words to
tighten us into a global uh economic
slowdown we're seeing this in mortgage
rates we had a three sigma rise in
mortgage rates on a trailing three-year
basis that is going to crush the housing
economy we've had a three sigma rise in
corporate borrowing costs on a trailing
three-year basis that's going to crush
the broader sort of productive capacity
of the economy and then we've also just
had a three sigma rise uh in real
ten-year treasury yields that's going to
take out a lot of the sort of leverage
and speculation we've seen in financial
assets which obviously is happening on
our screens this week